now we are also hearing from the
families of those involved in this
tragic situation from yesterday Bianca
Holmen spoke with a woman whose cousin
survived
you have to drive for everybody and I
just I'm
I'm really I'm really pissed off that
this happened Tamika Henry's cousin
Tiffany May is in the hospital
recovering after a multi-vehicle crash
Henry returned to Cheyenne and commerce
with a dog rescue group to find her
cousin's dog magic magic was in the car
with May thankfully they found the dog
she's so giving and loving and will do
for others and will give the shirt off
her back and and I know that even if she
had the capacity to help yesterday and
the strength too she would have got up
and and she would have done that North
Las Vegas Police say a Dodge Challenger
was speeding Northbound ran a red light
and crashed into several Vehicles the
driver of the Dodge Challenger died in
the crash eight others died and a total
of 15 people were involved victims range
in age from teens to middle-aged adults
speeding is not the answer please slow
down and please pay attention to
everyone around you Henry is a Las Vegas
native and has lived in the area for 20
years she witnessed his speeding often
it is absolutely really disgusting that
in this day and age that people choose
to disobey laws while Henry's cousin has
a long road of healing ahead her heart
hurts for everyone we don't know come
Monday morning
when these when these youth find out
that their classmates possibly
classmates have passed away we as a
community have a duty and obligation to
be there for the families the families
and the children affected by this
tragedy Bianca Holmen live local now